frederick is with us frederick is in
texas
hi frederick how are you i'm doing very
well mr ramsey and mr hogan thanks for
taking the call
our pleasure how can we help uh so i
just had a quick question on
i'm 22 i'm gonna be graduating from
school in about a year and a half
and i'll be graduating with graduating
with about 35 000
in student debt and so my my question is
right now should i double down with my
time on school
so that i can you know have the highest
paying income
i could have out of college or should i
you know
take out a second job or a side job
right now to try to take advantage of
the fact that
um you know there's a there's a freeze
on the interest rates for the student
loans and
tackle though that's that's my question
frederick what year are you in school
i so technically i'm a senior but i'm
going to be graduating in five years
because i switched from neuroscience to
finance
five years from now i don't know five
years total so
a year and a half from today so i have
three semesters total
i feel better already yeah okay yeah
and do you have the money set aside to
pay for the remaining of school you have
left
i i do not so it's all student loans so
this like the total
like it'll be all student loans all the
way through and then um
my dad has a good chunk of it in parent
plus and then he put some in my name so
i have i have 35 total when i graduate
well i'm going to tell you this my
friend i love the spirit of you wanting
to get that debt out of your life but
first and foremost
as dave will tell you the best
investment you can make is in you
and so i would want you to get money set
aside to make sure you're not having to
add
any more student loan debt to this 35
000 right we're at that limit
and so once you have that in place and
you're paying for your school moving
forward
then i want you to turn your attention
to attacking the debt
uh but i don't want you signing any more
of those papers in the financial aid
office they're not your friend
so here's here's the thing there's no
point in paying down your student loans
while you're continuing to borrow
that's filling up the hole with one
shovel and the other hand's digging it
out at the same time
you're just swapping dollars dude does
that make sense no it makes sense
yeah so let's your first goal is work
your butt off and
limit or alleviate the future need for
more borrowing from today forward let's
get out without any more borrowing that
would be goal
one paying down the student loans that
are the currently there i wouldn't worry
about until after graduation
but your main goal now is to add no more
debt and yes i would work and do that
and i think i heard you say
uh double down on school so i get a
better job
there are very few jobs that pay you
more for
a 4.0 than the for 3.0
like none
okay i i've been interviewed for jobs
and interviewed for
all kinds of things uh interviewed in
the press and everything else over the
last 40 years of my life
and i can tell you the number of times
someone has asked my gpa when i was in
school
was zero how many times you're yeah i
know you got
a master's in finance but no i've not
been asked my gpa you got a master's in
finance nobody asked you what that was
but when they were in your best-selling
book yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i mean we're not telling him to hold
back no because i have this
potential now but this idea that if i'm
going to work my grades are going to
suffer
usually they don't number one no that's
true that's not a
it's not a given and then number two if
you're working
and your grades do suffer a little it's
not going to mean you don't get a job no
that's true
um and if you get if you're being hired
by people who the difference in a
a 3.5 and a 4.0 or a 3.0 and a 3.5
matters that's not some place you want
to go to work anyway these people are
freaks
you don't really want to work there
there's some strange individuals yeah
aliens
yeah one eye in the center of their head
something off star wars queen really you
don't want that does that
yeah yeah so no i um you get to work
dude
and no more student loans no more bust
your butt and get your butt in class
and no partying quit playing beer pong
this
is the ramsey show